foreign
and he was sitting there and he said I
just start seeing the Satan devil will
lie and he said he's telling his
girlfriend I want to leave I'm Gonna
Leave so he left he said then I started
thinking about Islam
and he came and alhamdul gave him Tower
he became Muslim he said how's that some
crazy things in the church bro he he
just made he messaged me that's my
brother he's my bro from the ends but
yeah you see with me he just messaged me
he's like yo when are you going what's
next time shout me yeah
you know we believe in Jesus no doubt we
believe it was a great messenger it was
a true Messiah however the Pagan the
Roman pagans change his teaching
especially Paul Paul you know Paul you
know Paul it was it was no one to kill
the Christians
the stories then we can pull then what
happened he said one day he was going to
Damascus on his wrist that was because
Jesus appeared to him
but I believe and as many indications
indicate that that Paul what he did he
noticed the true flows of Jesus that he
was killing they were strong in their
faith they don't want to give up their
faith so what he did he change the
tactic
so you want to crack them from within in
the stand that's why even historically
speaking it is known that Paul had a
problem with uh
and um I think it's Mark Mark
but I know for a fact he has problem
with the James
uh Jesus have brother
because
yeah called James James yeah yeah I mean
that's not his name you know the
translation even Jesus his name is esos
you know so he had a half brother
according to the Bible and you can see
there's a there was a problem between
him and Paul because Paul came he said
it's not about the law anymore it's
about faith
of the heart
you see so Jesus was circumcised or the
the Israelites from the teaching because
God said in the Old Testament one of the
signs between me and the people
and Abraham is circumcision the actual
one no of the heart all he was corrupted
so we love Jesus it was a great
messenger but his teaching was corrupted
and of course the most wise will not
leave us with a corrupted teaching
to us make sense that's why we said
Prophet Muhammad Islamic teaching he
goes in line with our sound reasoning
with our natural inclination we don't
believe in God become a baby
that doesn't make any sense bro yeah if
God become a baby cannot be good he's
not good anymore because God's not a
baby a baby is not God understand
likewise we look to the to the Judaism
Judaism God became tired or regrets or
he was worried that people language so
Islamic teaching how I describe himself
Allah
is one is unique Allah is a master
self-sufficient everything is in need of
him he's not in need of nothing
himself and even there's other out
there's other names Allah al-jabbar the
compeller and Aziz the almighty al-karib
the most generous the most merciful are
we that the strongest and as is the
almighty and so on Allah Allah describe
himself Quran and you look at this
universe it makes sense Allah the
creator of this universe you understand
imagine I said to you the creator of
this phone it was someone who was
completely paralyzed
especially iPhone is so complicated
design and so on you understand so when
you look at Allah's creation and how
Allah describe himself in the Quran he
makes sense bro and you know
of course you're aware there's a huge
wall against human nature enough with
this transgender movement and lgbtq and
and all of these you know day and you
know until this funny story my friends
and English back home so he learned he
or a man she for a woman so he started
working uh come over the place and so
there was a woman working with him she
doesn't like to be called she
she likes to be called day
so he went to his boss and he said you
know she was telling me he said no no
she it's day he said day who's day he
said day he said what is day he said he
said sir back home I'll dance in English
courses she women they more than one
person as only one woman what are you
saying they he said no no she likes to
be called day he said
dot com in the standard how silly how
ridiculous
man he's his husband money back home
paying for English courses me
and now you ain't nobody wants us to be
they want us to be blind followers
literally they want us to be like sheep
because I feel
I feel inside me I'm an elephant so you
have to call me elephant otherwise I'll
be offended
and I would say I'll call the police on
you
bro the guy literally is a man but he
feels it's something else so I have to
then I would I have to poke my eyes and
I say sorry I have to deny my own eyes
what's this all about that's what Islam
comes in it's teach you to be firm we
don't back down for no one and we don't
bow down to No One except Allah
Christianity is dying in Europe
[Music]
that's why the war that is taking place
against human nature is taking place
against Islam because they've noticed
the only religion that is standing firm
against the evil ones is Islam you know
about education yeah yeah this brother
Andrew church will preachers I was just
thinking about that right before you
said it was literally
yeah you know that brother help him no
dog has been oppressed you know like
it's subhanallah how many months now
he's in jail
there's nothing
of course because he was not Muslim
before he said say things we should
agree with but overall always be
oppressed look guys if you agree with
him or not but one thing that he said
yeah and I always use because he's a
multi-millionaire yeah he said I saw the
Satan with my own eyes
yeah you know he said because why he's a
multi-millionaire he was invited by the
evil the secret societies the elites the
elites yeah you know that is you know
these prime minister's president no no
these guys just pictures there's people
behind the elites so so he said I met
them and they wanted they want to
manipulate me but he said so and you
when I started looking to Islam other
reasons and so the only religion that is
standing film against his evil people
who will destroy him in nature is Islam
he said that's why I'm a Muslim you know
so because well like I said Islam tell
you to worship the true God because when
you don't know what she was true God
what happened you start you start
drinking alcohol or you start doing
every evil things that's why Islam came
to preserve five Kings
that's what makes Islam very special and
it makes sense why Muhammad is the
message of Allah because these five
things if we do preserve them we will
have good Society healthy Society okay
so Islam came to preserve religion what
does that mean it means Islam will not
allow you to pray to Prophet Muhammad
we're not allowed to preach any human
beings or any creature we only pray to
the Creator to the true creator so
that's why paganism politicism is
forbidden Islam came to preserve
intellect
that's why drinking alcohol drugs is
forbidden Islam came to preserve wealth
that's what interest and gambling is
forbidden Islam came to preserve
marriage and family and lineage and
Heritage that's why adultery and
fornication is forbidden Islam kept
Reserve lying that's why killing people
and justly committed suicide is
forbidden these five things if we do
preserve that we'll have a healthy
Society a good Society where is opposed
of that alcohol alcohol is bad for us
individually and collectively gambling
is bad for us individually and
collectively interest likewise May the
rich future and a poor poorer also
foreign
families these vices it goes back to the
most evil thing which is what which we
call
disbelief and politicism
when we start worshiping the first God
which and with God so this Vice is
alcohol gambling interests and other
things there is some people who are
benefiting from them who are they those
who are in power that's why they see as
they look at Islam as a threat for their
business
that we can Pro if people accept Islam
I'm gonna go bankrupt and be broke yeah
maybe you're broke so I'm gonna have a
I'm a rich man so I'm gonna do I'm gonna
utilize my money my money to make Islam
look bad even though deep down the hill
Islam is good for mankind so that's
what's happened now they're using social
media and they're using the media
General speaking to make Islam look bad
even though Islam is good for us
individually and collectively so the
question you ask yourself how a man that
existed 1400 years ago Prophet Muhammad
who couldn't read and write is coming
who is the perfect way of life
from the Almighty I believe Jesus came
with the same thing but like I said they
corrupted Jews teaching like was Moses
but Prophet Muhammad should be preserved
the Quran is a miracle one of the milk
of the Quran Allah made it easy for us
to memorize it
you know now I can write a o c u but I
kind of clear that's the order my people
memorized it he said no no it's a b c d
people memorize the alphabet yeah so the
Quran we memorize it with our hearts and
while the milk of the Quran you go to
Nigeria uh Angola Africa generally
speaking Europe America Asia you see
Muslims at the age Muslims at the age of
9 10. and word for word later for later
and Allah mentioned that in the Quran
one thousand four days ago Allah
mentioned you make easy for people to
memorize it and allow preserve it not if
the Jews and the Christians and the
Muslims all of them decide to Bear the
scripture
will get back they will write it back
easily not the Muslims not the Muslims
call us there was no kids yeah I'll give
you I'll give you another one yeah I'll
give you another this one's so true you
could get a very very disobedient Muslim
that memorized parts of the Quran he
wouldn't make him mistaken a lot of the
verses but you could get the most
so-called righteous Christian to recite
maybe one part of the Bible the whole
page will he'll make mistakes
you make mistakes because it's simple
God made it easy to memorize this book
he didn't make it easy to memorize that
yeah he said himself he's come here in
his own will bro he said to me himself
the Quran just sounds amazing
I think this will happen to me no one's
telling me it happened to me 2007 he
used to come to my house and cut my hair
there and it was easy so I I said to him
I I think you forget it but you know
what you came to my house and I remember
I had to go to the shop chicken to buy
Virgo so I went it was at 11 30 or
midnight when I went to the chicken shop
there was an Irish guy there and he was
asking me do you know in a hotel because
why the train there's no more trains he
lives far away I said it is a hotel
around the area
so I told him he left then when I was
going to my house I should live in White
City I saw him he said bro you know
there's no hotels I said no problem come
to my house yes I come stay at my house
there was a day day after so he came to
my house and I was about to go sleep I
said I played the Quran for him
and he was like bro what's this I said
why
he says you know I'm feeling like
something within me in me you know like
peace you know yeah we're lying and I
said
recital he has a good voice
let me add Channel yeah let me change
another reciter yeah and uh who's
listening I said who do you feel about
this one he said safely I said this is
the speech of Allah of your creator
you know so I'll give him a leaflet I
don't know what happened to him
and I left in the morning but the point
is one of the milk and he has authority
over the hearts
that's the the greatest miracle in the
stand so alhamdulillah what if everyone
said make sense
so you know
it won't accept Islam alhamdulillah you
become a servant of your creator because
let me tell you something in this life
you cannot Escape your options either
you become a slave of your if your
creator or you're going to become a
slave of your desire and a Satan no
doubt about it even those people who say
I'm free
what he means I just follow my desires
so you are a slave of your desire
exactly whoever you desire and tell you
to do you do it you're a Slave
because we are allowed to us to do we do
it but you have a desire and you desire
he has evil in it but Allah is the holy
the all good you understand so in this
life either you're going to become a
slave of Allah
follow his teaching or you're going to
become a slave of your desire and by
extension or state of the Satan and the
desire and by extension you become a
slave of your Society is
good fasting is good for you giving
charity is good for you the prayer
likewise bro you know
suicide
is going is inclining
in the Western World bro from Nigeria
you know of Algeria back home you know
those ignorant ones they want to come
here if you come here that's
everything's easy you know people people
born here raised up here people are
coming to Suicide why because they turn
away from God they're gonna study it's
an Islamic community have the lowest
rate of suicide yeah yeah I know yeah
your body when you fast
your body goes through something called
Effigy Effigy and it means your body
starts healing itself yeah yeah so
whenever they treat cancer
um homeopathically the first thing they
tell you to do stop eating when you have
cancer stop eating you can't eat for a
long period of time and when your body
starts healing itself because it gives
your body time the cells yeah to
replenish and of course 1 400 years ago
this is legislative
yeah of course
yeah yeah of course you know there's a
doctor in return he said it's good for
the people to fuss twice a day twice a
week twice a week yeah University Monday
or Thursday yeah twice a week and from
the voluntary first Muhammad taught us
so fast twice a week Monday or Thursday
and we are not in need of science to
astonish Islam the truth Islam is the
truth independently you know Islam is
not a need like when it comes to
Christianity because Christians are in
need of the Old Testament to approve
their beliefs we are not in need of none
of the books only the Quran and the
prophetic teaching study it and look at
it it's simple and clear that this is
the truth do you understand even on
another study they said
they said that I think there's even more
due dates or or
um
per gram
it has the highest source of
carbohydrates in parallel of any fruit
program so if of course if you've gone
the whole day without eating yeah that's
the most
like logical thing to eat because it's
the smallest amount but the most
carbohydrated yeah it keeps you going
yeah
so if you're Muslim you don't need to
wait for science Islam is ahead of
science
he said to eat all the amount of dates
from the ajwa exactly yeah three three
or five one three or five yeah seven
yeah
if it makes sense to you we need to
become Muslim just just go on for what
he said yeah like even just
Islam being a head of science right in
my head growing up I've always had a
issue with Christianity just the whole
idea that
that everything had to everything had to
make sense for them and I'm saying that
everything it's just convenient yeah I'm
saying but with Islam I feel that
yeah it's not about making sense
Christianity is not about making what is
about Christianity it's about believing
that's why it's our Christianity but
when you Islam because Christianity is
about belief
okay it's called I I have my own belief
is enough that's why the Christians they
cannot prove their beliefs
you kind of challenge like you tell me
how God become a baby but at the same
time it's all powerful but God is
getting pizza
Islam Islam goes allowed our sound
reasoning understand that you know
because why
the one who creates us he created us
with the tools which I could Universal
choose which cause
Nation or observation Islam Islamic
Clicks in it harmonizes so well
he's his own man you don't understand
him to be here but he don't listen to No
One yeah you can't like
when he misses me
him bro
[Laughter]
when I say convenient I mean in the
sense that for things that don't make
sense to me yeah it was just that just
believe yeah that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah I'll tell you something because I
come from a Christian background I used
to sometimes go to Christian circles to
find one even though I didn't find him
there I noticed that the Christians were
ready to bend any rule was the Muslims
that were straight with it nah you can't
do that yeah they were talking about in
a Christian Circle yeah this is just my
personal experience our subjectivity
they were saying that it's okay the
woman that you have intercourse with you
don't actually have to love with him
they'll man some crazy kalanas some
really crazy speech I was like bro
what's going on that's impermissible in
this religion the guy's talking about
just bending rules for the sake of you
know desire
but the Muslims now know straight away
no you can't do that
clear yeah of course but you're right
it's about the there's that you believe
and and that's it you know that's the
problem you understand that you know
body comes to Islam no because Islam it
makes perfect sense but that's why
emotions Islam today today
in Philly 19 people met a homeless guy
today bro who's in McDonald's car park
here on the way I picked him up we met
homeless man yeah
are you he said he said he said he told
me Jesus tattoo I said is that God he
said uh no I said who's got them he said
God is God that's not God okay cool I
said he said I said what language did
Jesus speak he said Jesus spoke Aramaic
I said you're knowledgeable he's
homeless yeah I said in Aramaic you said
it not me in Aramaic how do you say God
just Islam being ahead of of um science
it's like how can they not work can only
come from God yeah of course they're 100
yeah it's like you know interest you
know like banks in there but he was just
speaking about it yeah he said to us you
will come a time will become widespread
even if you are not involved directly
affect you even if you're not involved
directly in the interest transaction it
will affect you now but therefore if you
open a bank account what happened even
your phone yeah it costs more yeah yeah
it's crazy you can't escape it even send
us by food yeah you have to pay for
interest it's crazy how Amanda existed
1400 years ago knew about something that
we could observe right now is the one
thing there's many many things bro and
you know you said you can't write or
read of course not limitation no that is
a proof that you
writing because that for him it was a
virtue
he took mankind civilization he took
mankind what is a true knowledge that is
a miracle because if you studied and you
are learning person you teach us okay
you'll learn that one but someone
couldn't really write he's coming with
this perfect way of life through him
people being guided been civilized been
uh
coming out of Darkness into light
he's not a person he was talking
I think
what man what he really understood is
that I'm not I'm not sure which place it
is in the Quran but there's a verse
where Allah says
um a lot basically is challenging people
to bring bring a book like this isn't it
okay yeah
for someone to make that challenge yeah
you have to be all annoying or you can
embarrass yourself that's right you have
to know this book doesn't exist anywhere
yeah because if you make that challenge
and someone even one percent chance they
find a book yeah this religion is gone
so for someone to make that type of
challenge typically they have their own
and they know this book is nowhere else
yeah and like I said Tim till today
we're still waiting you know yeah
yeah there's many verses and you know he
did not just he did not just challenge
them once because maybe once even you
just said a quick thing you know they
didn't hit him
he kept saying look bring something like
it yeah bring it in his eloquency
legislation prophecy structure and and
the beauty of the Quran
so powerful man one question I do have
so you see how um
the story of Adam and Eve yeah
um the Apple yeah um we don't have his
Apple
in the Bible
yeah we're not sure what is it yeah
um
we became knowledgeable you know what
I'm saying who I mean we became
knowledgeable mankind he's saying in the
Bible yeah they took the fruit
and then all of a sudden
no no no
Islamic teaching it was a lot to Adam
because remember the Angels when Allah
created Adam Adam they say why are you
creating him so Allah was to shorten the
virtues of Adam over them so Allah
taught many things to Adam not because
he ate from tree or not Allah to him
inspired him so Adamas asked Andrews to
name some things they could name it they
didn't know when Allah asked Adam Adam
name them
looking for Adam
would you say then that um the Quran is
um is a way for us to navigate this
knowledge no doubt about that yeah Quran
is for us as a guideline
also as a criteria to verify the
previous information for example in the
Old Testament it says God create the
heavens and the Earth and always in
between them in six days oh it doesn't
say oh it's between them it's a good
credit in six days and a seventh day
rested in a book of numbers he said
rested and refreshed yeah in the Quran
Allah
we have created the heavens and the
earth and the oceans between them in six
days and no fatigue overcame us Allah is
saying that Allah is refuting the lies
that has been attribute to him in the
previous books that he became refreshed
and arrested because to rest under the
flesh is attribute of created being in
the stand
he's free from these imperfections yeah
like for example if you do a run or you
play football you're tired of your
breakfast God is free from these
imperfections yeah
so so that story even about uh the story
of the the story of Jesus in the Quran
is make makes more sense than the story
of the Bible
serve the Quran I like made Jesus speak
in the Cradle because it's a miracle
because the Jewish people there was one
new or stone a woman to death if she
commit adultery that's right so Allah
give a miracle but the people imagine it
I mean like imagine a woman comes now
she's not married I had a child
God gave it to me well
I imagine fornicated or something yeah
okay but if she made it okay I'm gonna
prove to you God give it to me the child
is going to speak to you he's in the
Cradle miracles
[Music]
are very much suitable for their time
so anything that the prophets and
Messengers came with it was suitable for
the people at that time to understand
and recognize wait a minute nobody can
replicate this yeah nobody for example a
man said oh you know what we can build
two buildings that's a miracle that I'm
a profit you'll be like wait a minute we
have that technology here yeah but a man
say that 1400 years ago he had no
stethoscope he was out in the desert
Barren land and he's predicting these
things obviously for specific people to
have very specific unique people yeah
you see it oh they were more likely to
be destroyed exactly yeah start building
remember because the Roman the Persians
they were coming after them and by
stealing them you'll build things make
sense really take shadow
alhamdulillah I'm gonna say in Arabic
then I say then English
yes
in English I bear Witness
there's nothing there's no worthy of
worship
in truth except Allah
and that their Witness
the Muhammad
is the last messenger
and the servant of Allah
[Music]
congratulations